a flow is technically defined as an
optimal state of consciousness a state
of consciousness where we feel our best
and we perform our best it refers to
those moments of total absorption when
we get so focused on the task at hand
that everything else disappears so our
sense of self our sense of
self-consciousness they vanish time
dilates which means sometimes it slows
down you get that freeze-frame effect
familiar denim you seen the matrix I've
been in a car crash sometimes it speeds
up in five hours will pass by in like
five minutes and throughout all aspects
of performance so mental and physical go
through the roof underneath the flow
state is a kind of complicated mass of
neurobiology there are fundamental
changes in neural anatomy which is where
in the brain something's taking place
neural chemistry and/or electricity
which is the two ways the brain
communicates with itself the most
prominent is the neural anatomical
changes so the old idea about ultimate
performance flow is what's known as the
10% brain myth the idea that we're only
using 10% of our brain at any one time
so ultimately ously be the full brain
firing on all cylinders and it turns out
we had it exactly backwards in flow
parts of the brain aren't becoming more
hyperactive they're actually slowing
down shutting down the technical term
for this is transient meaning temporary
hypofrontality hypo hyp OS the opposite
of hyper means to slow down to shut down
to deactivate and frontality is the
prefrontal cortex the part of your brain
that houses your higher cognitive
functions your sense of morality your
sense of will your sense of self all
that shuts down so for example why does
time pass so strangely in flow because
David Eagleman discovered the time is
calculated all over the prefrontal
cortex when parts would start to wink
out we can no longer separate paths from
present from future were plunged into
what researchers call the deep now
transient hypofrontality is interesting
it was discovered back in the 90s and
had very negative connotations it was
found in schizophrenic sand drug addicts
and then in the early thousands our
Dietrich who was then at Georgia Tech
discovered or hypothesized that
transient hypofrontality actually
underpins every altered state Dreaming
meditation flow drug addiction doesn't
really matter
and then in 2007-2008
Charles Lim at Johns Hopkins working
with first jazz musicians and second
with rappers was looking at flow in
those context and found that the
prefrontal cortex was shutting down as
well though depending on the altered
state you get different different parts
are shut down like in flow one of the
most prominent examples is the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex shuts down in
flow this is the part of the brain that
houses your inner critic that nagging
defeatist
always on voice in your head turns off
and flow and as a result we feel this is
liberation right we're finally getting
out of our own way we're free of
ourselves creativity goes up risk-taking
goes up and we feel amazing my mission
for the past 15 years has been swimming
to reclaim flow research from the hippie
community from the New Age community and
put it back on a really hard science
footing and really what that took was
flow research has been going on
continuously that kind of both here in
the United States and Europe all over
and it really just took synthesizing all
the information and bringing it together
and putting it on a hard neurobiological
footing that said there's a bunch left
to do right we have a hundred fifty
years of flow psychology and flow
science goes back all the way to the
1870s in fact some of the earliest
experiments ever run in kind of early
neuroscience and early kind of
Experimental Psychology were run on flow
in the past 25 years as our brain
imaging technology has gotten better and
better and better we can look farther
into the brain and see what's going on
we've got about 25 years of neurobiology
that's underpinning and I sort of think
it starts with dr. Andrew Newberg at the
University of Pennsylvania who was
looking he was actually looking at
spiritual experiences in meditating
Tibetan Buddhists and Franciscan nuns
and he found that quote unquote state of
cosmic unity when we become one with
everything is actually a byproduct of
transient hypofrontality as well so what
happens when the type of friend le moves
out of the prefrontal cortex and back
into the right parietal lobe which is
the part of the brain that separates
self from other right it allows us to
walk through
crowded rooms not bumping into people
and things along those lines in flow
this portion of the brain shuts down so
we can no longer separate myself from
others so when people talk about feeling
one with everything
you'll get it in action sports surface
will talk about being one with the waves
mountain climbers one with the mountain
whatever it is for Buddhists it's cosmic
unity it's one with the universe but
what's really happening is the portion
of the brain that's separate itself from
other is shut down so we can no longer
distinguish between the two things and
as a result we feel one with everything